[Musica]
ciao a tutti e benvenuti sanità stories
oggi nuovo video molto particolare
andiamo a distruggere cose con un mega
martello 7 o in slow motion quindi al
rallentatore così possiamo vedere bene
come si distruggono abbiamo una serie di
oggetti è una volta a testa andremo a
distruggere gli oggetti fuori il
martello
in più il macchinone distruggeremo un
oggetto potrete votare nel sondaggio da
1 a 10 quanto siamo stati bravi a
distruggere col martello molto abbiamo
tirato forte ma se abbiamo tirato tirato
troppo piano
un punteggio più basso così poi alla
fine vedremo se ho vinto io o se ha
vinto vitale se volete secondo episodio
di distruggiamo le cose slow motion la
siete belle la x6 possibili raggiunge i
10 mila likes andremo a fare il secondo
fra gli studios occhiali e mi raccomando
non fatelo a casa lasciate che siamo noi
a fare questa cosa da fare è pazzo
prende dei pop corn video a tutto
schermo e iniziamo subito con il primo
set
allora primo oggetto è questo scrissi la
striscia può chiedere immediate ritirò a
distruggerlo non penso prof
però vediamo un po come diventerà qui
c'era acquisti siamo pronti re dove
poi è il primo oggetto fatto è intatto
purtroppo però insomma è molto
resistente questo si è visto comunque un
pochettino di non vedere o rivedere in
reati come slow motion quando hanno
schiacciato quindi molte donne 10 quanto
vi è piaciuto questo slow motion
anche se questo squizzi non si è rotta
su una troppo ora tocca a vitale attivo
oggetto che spetta a vitale è un altro
scrissi
vitale riuscirà a distruggerlo e come
sarà cosa suo socio è pronta ma solo
moltissimo occhiali protettivi e poi
facciamo pronti a distruggerlo
[Musica]
30 maggio che uscivano le perle di
favori però anche questo non si è rotto
date un voto qua a questo slow motion
e qual è il prossimo oggetto mi intriga
questa bat bomba perché non so se il
martello la distruggere un secondo te
resisterà al martello o la distruggerà
non doverla distruggere secondo voi
scrivete nei commenti ad esso
se il martello distruggerà la bat bond
possa labate bomb vincerà lei allora
proviamo a lasciare la pellicola così
magari non facciamo un kart il prodotto
effettuiamo cosa succede considerando
che io non tiro molto forte diamo se
riusciva de vivre ora tirare più forte
in area dato che
[Musica]
ha una fantastica una figata
allora ho dovuto colpire più volte per
distruggerla però ne forza sempre
all'appello che è tutto non vedo l'ora
di vederlo
sì sì polverizzata vedete diventano
proprio esaminiamo v wow
l'inizio è piaciuto l'acceleratore
presente distruggono e super divertente
quindi votatelo pure qua questo slow
motion
noi andiamo a fare un bel bagno con
questa bomba e poi torniamo a sedere
come prossimo jazz nomos il cubo dire
come impero però è un po difficile da
rompere secondo me questo però se si
riesce è una figata
mi raccomando gli occhiali di protezione
perché questa è pericolosa
[Musica]
poi se non pensavo che sarei riuscito a
riguardo della narrazione ci sono altri
pezzi che si stava staccando ma ho preso
una grande portale vero e proprio
attaccato un quadratino e quello al 48
facciamo adesso invece sono deboli
casillas con l isee li tolgono così se
si vuole barare quello porto notare tra
un cubo nei due lati
abbiamo quasi fatto il cubo di rubik
ammontate in quanto vi piace questo c'è
un orso questo lo abbiamo rimandato
subito perché era un mostro fu curiosi
che figata il trasferimento è rimbalzato
con tagli sono parte studenti del liceo
è troppo divertente ed ora sono in
decisa perché abbiamo qua uno slide
racchiuso dentro una bustina quindi
quello che speriamo è che una volta
colpito per il martello andrà a
esplodere e uscirà fuori dalla routine
ha così chiarito questo troppo dire
tutta la regione
quello sempre crede o per preparare
confronto io saprò per questo ci vuole
un colpo molto forte per distruggere e
far esplodere questo strano poi abbiamo
un mandarino che io spero che esploda
con un colpo di martellata ma non ne
sono sicura secondo te riuscivo a farlo
esplodere questo non lo so forse si
trova con questo che è più facile perché
non diamo colpire troppo forte dai
terroristi harvey è fortissima secondo
te ce la faccio
[Musica]
allora cruz e figo però si vede poi
tutto macchiato di mandare in os x è
pieno di benzina schizza dappertutto per
punizione vicino però sta tutto di
mandarino della settimana tantissimo di
mandarino guardate come ridotto guardate
un colpo incredibile questo è stato una
figata da fare
mi dispiace un po per il povero
mandarino che l'abbiamo abbiamo fatto
una bellissima spremuta martino guardate
un po anche per terra mi sono sporcata
estremamente non si sporcano credibile
milioni camici avvolta per proteggere
qui non vi sono stata ma jim sporcato
tutto il resto però che figata
cioè non vedo l'ora di rivederla in 315
da un hard drive o trasparente secondo
te riuscirai a farlo esplodere ma io
credo desisterò pallottole force c'è più
resistenza e quindi riesce a bucarlo
segniamo perché sono troppo curiosa così
dobbiamo raccogliere anche allo slide
penso di mandarino perché allora siete
pronti
mettetevi comodi ti pronto prontissimo
il pronto a sferrare una super
martellata all'uso quanto mi piaccia me
lo sbaglio
[Musica]
saltato un paio di colpi porno sia
piatta lato non sia troppo credibile è
intatto la busta l'intatta è
indistruttibile questo slime pochissimo
meno se la corsa la contessa mio
battendo a sporco ecco cosa ha fatto mi
buco vediamo se riusciamo a farlo uscire
dalla busta dal minuscolo non è esploso
come si è buttato di esistere il sito e
con quasi sul plan trasparente esami
dire certi salvato slime ma non si è
salvato
notate questo snowmotion qua io ora
siamo arrivati alla fine però per la
fine abbiamo lasciato
le borse più speciale di tutti pronti e
ovviamente prima di finire l'episodio
consigliatissimi commenti che altri
oggetti volete che proviamo a
schiacciare con il martello in slow
motion
scriveteci tutti i voti pozzi che il
pieno e nel prossimo video se fai un
altro episodio andremo a schiacciare gli
oggetti che ci consigliate
ma ora siamo pronti allo 0 finale ho
detto prima del bus serata quando sul
gambo lo abbiamo detto e lo si chiamano
qua altrimenti avremmo sfondato il
tavolo ecco qua l'oggetto finale
purtroppo è già spaccato qua chi si
ricorda in quel video lo abbiano già
spaccato scrivete fluido nei conventi e
poi alla fine questo video vi lasciamo
il video in cui lo abbiamo spaccato così
andate a vedervi è piaciuto quel video
per ora in teoria tocca me adesso però
stavo pensando siccome vitale tira più
forte col martello
magari lo facciamo fare ogni tanto
abbiamo tratto lo slide potendosi sono
sicuramente però siccome è rotto dietro
sto pensando s1 ragioni anzi e
spacchiamo lo schermo davanti molto
interessante allora preparatevi
vedo che hai già posizionato il tutto
lei anche rialzato un fiocco se siamo
sicuri di prenderlo pronto mi raccomando
non deve fallire qua allora vedo che sei
già in posizione siamo pronti aspetta
aspetta
mi devo preparare no
[Musica]
thesis correlato si è stato un colpo
molto forte se si devono porre
l'orecchio molto forte anche anche a me
mia salute
ora vediamo la da vicino oddio proprio
qui al centro
certo che figata guerra e poi il nord
alla fine sono volati molti pezzi sono
rimasti più onesta ma pensa sono
abbastanza concentrati fino al tavolo ma
stai attenta vedo qualcuno per terra se
attenta vedere come e perché col m di
quota
che figata vediamo dietro non è poi così
della fotocamera fatto molto bene
comunque dietro e un altro è rimasto
giusto la spaccatura dell'altra volta e
basta rimasto piantato dietro che
davanti si è davanti si è proprio qui
l'ho presa si vede
e incredibile non vedo l'ora di vederlo
in slow motion comunque non telecom e
qua sotto e rimasto tutto intanto nè di
sì sì sì sono il centro possiamo portare
molto resistente ma vero è fatto di
metalli bellissimo stato una figata
buttati qua e fateci sapere questo
mostro piaciuto più di tutti siamo
l'inter è ancora vitale con quelle cose
là ti piace progetto vi è piaciuto più
di tutti i consiglieri sì che altri
oggetti da tempo residuo nei commenti e
lasciato un bel live se vuole sul nostro
pisodio di altre cose pazze che facciamo
corn e ora vi lascio qui l'altro video
in cui rompiamo le scatole con il
martello rocambolesca tono con il
martello
potete vedere la prima col tempo abbiamo
distrutto il retto e poi vi lascio alle
caselline possa pubblicare per vedere i
nostri altri video seme e cliccate su
quella che preferite